well I I think that's the women's fault
though like yeah because they picked
them like why why are you sleeping with
him like what why are you letting him
like why aren't you on birth control we
have 41 forms of birth control pick one
and like why are you why are you letting
him back a guy that would be a bad dad
get you pregnant like that that's stupid
like what you can't change men and like
as women I think innately we know who's
gonna stick around we know who isn't
so why why would you pick him and really
and truly it's a small percentage of
guys that are out here making baby
making machines bro it's a small passage
bro it's the guys like the guys that
aesthetically look like Derek Jackson
bro